[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with columnist at the article ali muraj
and broadcast and and columnist steve
richards they both are we'll back to
them in a moment so let's see what's on
some of those front pages for you now
well the metro has an image of crying
liverpool fans as the team and culture
secretary call for a probe into how fans
were tear-gassed at the champions league
final in paris
central banks are raising interest rates
in the most widespread tightening of
monetary policy for more than 20 years
according to analysis by the financial
times
the eye reports that boris johnson is
set to remove dozens of eu laws this
year in a bid to appease members of his
party and turn around low support
numbers after partygate
the telegraph has details about a new
post-brexit scheme that is reported to
allow students leaving universities such
as harvard and yale to get visas
the guardian refers to a leaked home
office report that claims decades of
racist immigration legislation is to
blame for the windrush scandal
the times reports ministers fear six
million households could face blackouts
this winter if russia goes further in
cutting off gas supplies to the eu
the express leads on calls for patients
who miss gp appointments to be fined
claiming it's costing the nhs more than
1.4 million pounds a day
the mail says a record 12 million people
is set to celebrate the queen's platinum
jubilee with street parties next weekend
and the sun claims harry and megan have
renewed their lease on frogmore cottage
in windsor despite their move to america
and reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
programme you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by ali mirage
and steve richards welcome to you both
good to see you let's start with the eye
and the suggestion here is that the
prime minister is planning to uh
eradicate certain eu laws to appease uh
members of his uh cabinet his well
actually of the conservative party ali
yes it looks like uh julian on the back
of uh the new measures on pounds and
ounces coming back uh the prime minister
who is under some pressure from the
right of the conservative party
particularly you've had the likes of
daniel hannon
david davis ian duncan smith all lining
up to criticize uh the prime minister's
uh policy and also the chancellor in
terms of how they're dealing with this
cost of living crisis they want tax cuts
uh which is all very well my my answer
to that would be look i'm a low tax
person myself i want to see low taxes
but there's a time and a place and now
is not really the time and the place but
johnson is under pressure so to throw
red meat to the right of his party he is
going to try and
come up with a bonfire of eu regulations
and to me this seems like a an attempt
to desperately find a purpose he knows
that he's behind in the polls by about
six points you could argue a labour
should be even further ahead um and he's
also trying to put partygate uh behind
him when there are still questions
persisting over that he's got a
privileges committee coming up
and and further investigations going on
into her party in his own flat so i
think that's what this is all about
and uh the eye steve is suggesting that
uh the regulations most likely to be
repealed will cover the environment
workers rights transport tax and health
and safety
let's see i mean when a prime minister
is in trouble he often
resorts to
a trick which
won him his greatest kind of triumph and
brexit won him the december 2019
election the pretence that it was done
and there was an oven ready deal
this has been spun for the monday papers
it's not remotely new when it was in the
queen's speech it's been
hailed many times before that but they
were going to do this bonfire of the
regulations many of the regulations
involved were introduced by britain when
they were in the eu
for british self-interest so be
interesting to see how many of them are
actually done it's also very
illuminating that this is what number 10
considers
what tory mps and party members want to
hear
a reiteration of a kind of this hard
brexit line will kind of keep him in
post
they always brief about brexit when he's
in any degree of trouble
now i wonder about that but if it's true
that this is what pleases them they must
be willfully gullible because as i say
this has been announced many times
before
let us have a look at the telegraph and
this is an interesting story um the
government uh trying to woo ivy league
graduates from universities like harvard
and yale with uh visas to work in the uk
ali
well look they're excellent universities
and the government is announcing this
plan to attract graduates from the top
50 universities in the world to come to
the uk without having job offers in
place
at the time of visa application they
have to show that they've got certain
amount of financial resources to come
over but they can get visas for up to
two years and they want to clearly
attract the best and the brightest to
play a role in bolstering the um the uk
economy which is all seems very sensible
the issue however is that we do have 1.3
million job vacancies in this country
we've got more vacancies than actually
people out of work and if you look at
certain sectors you can see the queues
already building up ahead of the holiday
rush at airports where there's a
complete lack of staff you look at the
backlogs in the um in people trying to
get driving tests htv driver shortages
and 7.8 percent vacancy rate in the
hospitality sector uh i wonder how many
of these uh harvard and yale graduates
will be doing those jobs so look i think
it's very welcome i think it's sensible
it's again the government trying to show
that it is in control of its own poi
spain points based immigration system
which again was one of the big things in
brexit but we also need to look at
people at the lower end of lower skilled
end of the spectrum who are also playing
vitally important roles in the economy
steve do you think it's a good idea or
perhaps not the the best time to to be
deploying this
it's darkly comic it's again it's a
brexit briefing for telegraph readers
who are mainly very pro-brexit and many
of them tory party members um
exactly that there is
huge labor shortages in this country
it's not really at that sort of top end
of kind of academics and geniuses
brilliant though it is if they're coming
over and by the way they could have come
over
pre-brexit too there is a chronic
shortage
in the nhs in hotels restaurants uh at
airports of labor and this story doesn't
address any of that
at all
um and so as i say there's a sort of
dark comic quality to it really um this
is an urgent issue this uh labor supply
crisis it's caused by several things
including dare i say it brexit and the
end of freedom of movement many people
have left and haven't been replaced
and um this doesn't address any of that
but it's aimed again saying we're taking
back control you know this is this is us
and it's again number 10 and the prime
minister
returning to the only moment which
he has decided defines him in a positive
glow
the
brexit election of 2019
but other
much deeper urgent issues are around at
the moment than the one brief to the
telegraph and you wonder again where the
tory mps are going to buy into this
whether they're going to be so willingly
gullible at these briefings incidentally
or rebriefing all of this was known this
points based system uh long before
tonight uh just for information the visa
will cost 750 pounds and is subject to
the immigration health surcharge also uh
let's move to the guardian and this uh
interesting story a 52-page analysis and
by an unnamed historian which the
guardian has got hold of suggesting the
british empire depended on racist
ideology in order to function uh and
this has played into the windrush
scandal the origins of the windruss
scandal it suggests ally
well the windrush scandal was a shameful
episode in the home office's history it
cost amber rudd her job 83 people
deported there shouldn't have been and
multiple other people
that
suffered
wrongly so i think that was a complete
disgraceful
period however
i would love to see the actual basis of
this report i think it should be made
public and i think people should make uh
their own analysis of it and the and the
arguments that is asserts i think there
is a general concern that i have that we
seem to be seeing race in everything
these days which i think is deeply
unhelpful not only do people from uh i
think minority i don't even know if you
can say ba any uh anymore people get
offended at everything these days but
from an ethnic minority
we're inca we're being more and more
encouraged to see race everywhere and
this to me smacks of a country which is
becoming one where you actually confer
preference from emphasizing your
difference
rather than emphasizing your commonality
and other things and that really deeply
disturbs me so i'd be very interested to
read the contents of this report and i
think it should be made public let's
have a look at the metro to to start off
with uh and that picture there that that
uh poor boy um
crying at uh disappointment and um
disgraceful uh behavior actually this is
a champions league that we're talking
about in paris and the liverpool club
and the culture secretary calling for an
investigation into fans being tear
gassed ali
look it's uh pretty appalling some of
the uh imagery on twitter coming out of
this with the french police actually
tear gassing
fans that at least ostensibly seem to
have perfectly valid tickets
and you look at some of the commentary i
mean henry winter the respective
footballing uh pundits saying that it
was actually the positioning of police
cars that really were kenneling people
almost into uh
sort of chaotic scenes over there and
you've got jason mcateer former
liverpool um player saying that his own
son was attacked and his wife was mugged
it's right that the culture secretary
has called for uefa to launch an
investigation into this because it looks
pretty shambolical we need to know what
what went on
steve
yeah i mean
there are many echoes in the papers
today or tomorrow uh with the 70s and
80s we're going to look at some others
later on um and this is one that there
seems to have been
uh in paris and in london last year
there seems to be now an inability to
run safely these big football matches um
and we need to find out what happened in
paris as there have been inquiries as to
what happened in wembley uh a year ago
and um it raises many issues and i
happened to be
at st pancras on saturday morning when
there were loads of liverpool people
going off to the game and the cues to
try and get on that train were just
beyond belief going way outside the
station and i gather one of the reasons
for the chaos was everything was
the fans were delayed getting
getting there but that doesn't uh
justify in any way what appears to be
appalling um acts by some of the police
and and poor organization so yeah we
need to find out what happened why it
happened so it seems to be part of a
depressing
common theme which is a failure now to
be able to organize these things and and
i'm not saying this in the case of paris
but certainly at wembley
uh
the fans were partly responsible
let us move uh on to uh partygate i'm
afraid ali again uh and this is a story
of the second party uh held by carrie
johnson at number 10. this is the abba
themed party and the one that um sue
gray uh didn't investigate
yeah it's really confusing about why
sugray uh didn't uh look at this
particular one at all
and look uh they had a party when they
shouldn't have had a party this was to
celebrate the departure of lee kane and
dominic cummings who carried johnson
didn't get on with uh and they could
have at least had the decency to play
some uplifting soulful house music but
they chose the winner takes it all by
abba no accounting oh no i won't have
you speaking out against abba now ally
look like i'm offending i'm offending
most of the populists with that comment
look the point is henry newman who's
very close to carrie johnson may be
hauled up in front of the uh privileges
committee because they can call who they
want to uh to discuss uh what happened
at this party and look this is going to
rumble on and on prime minister's not
going anywhere he's got the
heidelberginosaurus it's up to the 54
mps and the tory party as to what
they're going to do and i'm not holding
my breath very quickly steve labourer
are calling it another cover-up
well it is a mystery and it needs
solving why sue gray seemed to give up
with her investigation after the police
began its investigation and why the
police didn't then investigate uh some
of these uh gatherings more assiduously
it's taking the journalists to do it
rather than them so we need to find out
why
and
i suspect over the weeks or months we
will do